[Inaudible] professor Thomas Piketty.
[inaudible] I wish I could do this in French.
I wish I could do it in Swedish.
Well,
the thing is I can barely order order a glass of wine and let alone talk about
the economy in French. It says we shouldn't even try, uh, how is it for you to,
to be compared with Karl Marx?
Well, no, I have no, I have no problem with the publicity around the book.
As long as it gets more people to read the book, you know, this is fine,
this is fine with me. Uh, so look, this is a very different kind of book.
You know, this was written in 2014, 2013.
Mark's book was written in 1867. So this is a different world. So this is,
this has little to do. My book is more a book about the history of capitalism,
which is a bit different with what the [inaudible] or marks or other 19th
century economies could do because they had very little data.
So there is a where mostly, you know, theoretical speculation. Whereas my,
my work, I think, you know, if it was, uh,
successful is because for the first time it contains a lot of historical
evidence on an issue, which everybody cares about,
which is money and inequality. And, and, you know,
this has consequences for the life of peoples life of people who go on strike
as the life of people. You know, when they get married, when they divorced,
when, you know,
he says as consequences that are important in everyone's life,
and this is this theory of money.
Let's start, let's start at the very top, uh,
based on these data and based on the facts who, who owns the world today.
Well, if you let, if you look at the word level, it is true that today,
you know, the,
the estimate we have is that the top 1% whence
olders in the world will own around Alf of the world's total Wells.
And the bottom 50% would own a, you know, less than 5%,
probably less than 2%, 1%. Now, of course,
that's also due to the fact that you have very large international inequalities
between countries. If you look within countries, it's a bit less extreme, uh,
and it used to be even more unequal. You know,
you take a country like Sweden or France a century ago. Uh, the,
the top 1% of the population would own over 60% of
total wealth.
And one of the major discovery in my book is that it really took major
shocks world war one, world war two,
the great depression and the new social democratic policies or
new social and fiscal compromise that were adopted after the
sharks. And in particular after world war to finally have a more
equitable distribution of income and wealth. Now in recent decades,
starting around the 1980s and 1990s,
we have a new tendency to rising concentration.
We are not back yet to the level of concentration we had a century ago
in European countries, but the research,
a question which I think many people are asking is, you know,
is the middle class share in total wealth?
Is that going to shrink in the future? Is it going to expand?
Are we going to have a bigger and bigger middle class?
And these are very important questions and they answer,
and the answer is nobody knows, you know,
this depends on the policies that we choose.
Probably the main conclusion of my book is that, you know, unlike marks or,
or Kuznets in the 20th century,
I don't believe in deterministic economy clothes. I think it's the end.
It all depends on the, the policies that we choose. But if we don't have,
for instance, more fiscal coordination,
if we keep Irving competition between countries to attract companies
to attract, uh, I well, so I skilled individuals.
There's a risk in particular in Europe where we keep reducing,
uh, like for instance, corporate tax. You know, you remember as a recent, uh,
uh, look, Sean block leaks,
a scandal where we learned in Europe that the largest multinational companies
were not even paying the statutory tax rate of 10% for under profits.
It looks on books, they were paying 1%, 2%, so that in the end,
our small and medium size companies are paying higher,
effective tax rate than the largest company.
So now if we keep going in this direction,
I think there's a serious risk is the middle class feels that they are paying
more than the very rich and medium-sized companies most.
And the very large multi-national that our basic social contract, you know,
will be under stress because there's a risk that rising inequality in, in,
in Europe, if this continues can take proportions,
which are in complete contradiction, we are with our basic democratic.
Yeah. So in a way, we're moving, moving toward,
back towards this Downton Abbey society where the rich are the few
that.
From there, you know, and I have, no, my book is not a pessimistic book.
I think there are ways to regulate this, but this is a risk that we should,
we should, uh, we should assess.
I think it will be a mistake just to rely on natural forces, uh, to,
to, uh, to solve this problem. And so we have to be careful.
And when, when you talk about the 1%, uh,
the Richards, rich richest people in the world, in a way,
the 1% riches owning almost half the, the, the world,
uh, that, that that's being hammered.
Yeah. Those that would be the.
Top 1% in Norway also tubs 0.1% in Norway is the top 1% in the
world. It's a lot of people because the world is, it's a big planet,
that's 7 billion people. So, you know, eh, you know,
one person is seven 70 million people. So it's a big group.
So it's much more of a new, but if you, if you take, if you take it away.
So how, how much money do you,
do you need to have to be among the top 1% in the world.
Or in terms of wealth, uh, you know, above, uh, above 1 million,
a million dollar in net Wells, you will be.
That's it, that's it the truth. I never felt her part, or
I don't remember our slogan is affordable fares and everyone. So I'm sorry.
Nope. There's no problem with having some rich peoples and poor people.
Some middle people, as long as inequality remains within reasonable limits.
And as long as the different groups in societies, uh,
benefit from growth and globalization at comparable speed,
the problem is when the top wealth groups are rising, uh,
three, four times faster than the size of the economy,
you can see that you have a problem, you know? Yeah,
you cannot continue forever. At some point, we'll have to stop,
and this will stop somewhere now where we need stop with what level of
concentration of income and wealth. Nobody knows. So, you know,
there's no pilot in the plane, it's, uh, we, we need to,
we need to put a collective regulation on this. So I think we need,
I believe in market forces in globalization, in an open economy,
but I think we need at the same time,
strong democratic institutions to ensure that these powerful
forces are put in the right direction and that brought groups in the population
can benefit otherwise. Uh, you know,
there's a risk that if large groups in the population feel that globalization
does not work for them, that they will turn for nationalist solutions,
that they will turn. And, you know,
speaking from France with the rise of the extreme, right. Uh,
this is a very serious concern. And I understand that in Sweden,
this is a concern as well. And I think generally speaking,
we have to make sure that globalization benefits, not only to a small group,
but to, to very broad groups of the population.
And this is possible if we adopt the right policies,
but this is not what we are doing now.
But let's see. I mean, now you're in this Norwegian Swedish, uh, talk show, uh,
and let's use Norway and Sweden just as an example, because Norway is, is,
is really, I mean, it's, it's, it's all about return of investment. It's,
it's living from this huge fund, uh, and, and Sweden is not.
So would it be,
would it be fair to say that it can be an illustration of your point?
Yeah, it's a very particular situation.
You're not Norway and Sweden are among the richest countries in the world.
And these are also among the most egalitarian countries in the world.
Although inequality has increased substantially in a country like Sweden the
past 20 years, you know,
it is still as compared to the us or as compared to a number of other European
countries.
These are still pretty egalitarian society where the social model is working
quite well.
Now there's a particular issue with the accumulation of huge foreign
reserves in a country like Norway. And, you know,
I understand that some people in Norway feels that this is a,
like a revenge of a history where for a long time,
Sweden was sort of the owner of Norway and maybe Norway will be the owner of
Sweden in the, in the future. True. So, you know, that's life, it's yours,
but look, I think ILO, uh, creates inequalities,
which sometimes can be, can be a problem in the case of Norway and Sweden.
You know, we are all rich or maybe, you know, we don't care so much,
but if you think of the impact of all in terms of inequality in the world today,
you know, these creates extreme inequalities in particular in the middle East,
which sometimes are very difficult to deal with. Uh, in my, in my book,
you know, I, I, for instance, I, quote joke if you take the total, uh,
education, uh, budget of a country like Egypt,
which is a country with almost 100 million people, well,
this is 100 times less than the old revenues going to small countries
without population in the Gulf area, a few hundred kilometers away.
And now that kind of extreme situation where you have big millions of
young people, you know, we don't see a future. And then, you know,
Androids have billions of dollars in countries with no population.
I think this can create tension now, not in the case of Norway and Sweden,
everybody's rich, or, you know, this is much less of a problem, but I think,
you know, the actual relation of, uh,
of hundreds and millions of dollars in,
in small groups of the world population, uh,
whereas you have large countries with little development prospect as this is
clear. So ideally what should Norway do with itself? Well,
should give it to some kind of AIDS well found, you know, to AIDS AIDS,
to, to a world farm, to, to fight, to fight AIDS. That would,
that would be like, okay, it was the whole fun,
no way so productive and as such the, you know,
social and educational products that you would live with it, you know,
you will still be very rich. So not worried no way. And, you know, I think,
let me tell you, see,
let me say that very long run the impact of becoming a
run to your country and the social democratic values of Norway,
I think is a real issue. You know,
right now the foreign reserves as the equivalent of what,
about two years of GDP or two half years of GDP, you know,
when it gets to five years, 10 years of GDP and the return, you know,
if you have a 5% or 4% return and 10 years of GDP, it means you get,
you're going to have 40 or 50% of your domestic production just in foreign
capital income paid by the rest, the world. You know,
this is a situation we've never seen that in history, you know,
countries that is accumulating so much foreign reserves relative to its domestic
production and labor force, what's the impact in the long run.
And I don't know, that will be very interesting to see. I don't know.
We, we have actually in Norway and Sweden, um,
removed the inheritance tax, uh,
so that we are free to, to let, uh, uh, wealth move on for generations,
you know? Right. Uh, w what do you think about that?
Well, you know, the, the premise that at the same time,
you have a very high total tax burden.
So you have to text someone and in practice, you are very consumption tax.
You are very high tax on labor income.
So if you look the overall evolution of the tax system,
I would say that what does happen in a country like Sweden is that you tend to
tax a lot more of the low income and middle income groups,
and less those who have a lot of Wells to transmit now,
is this good in the long run? You know, I don't know,
I'm not saying we should tax returns at 100%, but 0%,
you know, this is really very small.
And if you look at other countries in Europe, you know,
you look at countries like Germany, Britain,
it gets us to Cannes France. You know,
you always have an inheritance tax in these countries and the top rate,
very large in your returns and not talking of a few hundred thousand euros,
but if you leave tens of millions of euros,
the top rate in all of these countries right now is about 40%,
sometimes 35, sometimes 45.
And I don't hear Mecca or Cameron saying that they want to
do like Sweden and go to 0%. And, you know, these are not very,
very left-wing politicians, centers and center,
right in the U S I don't hear that they have a 40% tax rate and Narita
in Japan. They just raised it to 55. It used to be 48.
I'm just saying 0%. You know, look,
there's one country in Europe, a large country, which is Italy and obelisk,
which put it at 0%. They have to say there. So this is the only country,
you know, Sweden. So if I look at large countries in Europe now, of course,
there's maybe one reason in Sweden for doing that is that you feel that as a
relatively small open economy, you have strong competition with nowhere,
with Finland, with Denmark. So you have no other choice.
I understand this argument. Now, the problem is that you should do that,
and you should do the same for corporate tax.
And you end up with a 0% corporate tax with the same argument.
And then at some point to pay for your schools and your federal system,
you will have to overtake someone. And this,
someone will be the taxpayer who cannot move. So typically the low skill,
medium, skilled taxpayers now is this boot for job creation, to overtax,
low skill and medium skilled labor incomes, the way we do in Sweden and Europe.
And, you know, at some point,
some of these social groups may feel that nobody cares about them. And,
and I think, you know, this general evolution to work more competition,
to attract ice kill I Wells I income groups.
I understand that each country is dividual is in that kind of trap. But then,
you know, the low skill, medium skill groups,
they already sometime losing from globalization because they are put in
competition with emerging countries, labor force,
if at the same time,
our tax system and our fiscal system is reinforcing this
by taxing less people were more advantage. And then more, you know,
I think in the long run that this will have political consequences.
Just about the inheritance tax. I want it, who's going to inherit you.
I was even thought about you. Haven't thought about that.
You're still young so I can see it. But I,
I think that I totally agree with you on, especially on very low,
very low income and large difference.